don't think the Bengals are a Landry
spot no I think they'll take Daniels or
price
oh you think they've like been so on it
all like I almost said if that was it
would have been bad I don't even know
what you're about to say you're on oh
gosh so Connor let's get this pick baby
you're on to it because it's Billy price
yeah they were gonna take rack no no
will he be ready for camp yeah I talked
to him a couple days ago he's gonna be
good okay yeah and this is another Ohio
State kid that got to stay in the state
of Ohio yeah I love Billy price man yeah
it's pretty it's you look at this
offensive line they got Cordy Glen at
left tackle they got Clinton bowling at
left guard Jake Fisher's gonna have to
figure it out a right tackle their
centers TJ Johnson and their right guard
was Trey Hopkins they need an interior
offensive line Bradley Connor I'm gonna
give this a name Lamar Jackson to the
Ravens next pick I mean are we I'm gonna
get an hour Landry to the Ravens at 22
actually is incredible I'm gonna give it
an A as well you're hypothesizing urine
a yeah Billy urine a plus
yeah cool you didn't just that Pig
didn't happen here no no I'm just
thinking we did a video the other day
where Simpson Harold Landry could be the
next terrell suggs and now he's falling
to the Ravens at 22 injuries for him are
obviously a concern and that's why he's
still there all right we were gonna do
Billy price the true center going to the
Cincinnati Bengals
Cincinnati Bengals have been drafted a
lot of offensive lime in the last few
years but they haven't really seemed to
hit but I'll tell you the excitement
just coming off of this guy of happy
eating this might be the one Billy price
Ohio State staying in the same plug and
play he could play guard for you you
could play Center was a team captain
weight room freak great player a
finisher on the field you said he could
play right guard he could pull he can
trap he could get to the second level
and man he will put some defenders in
the dirt first team all-american little
old already 23 years old since this kid
pop off the film for what he does he
pops off the film he's six for 312
pounds he's a stout center he's a little
different than like a frac Frank rag
know who got drafted out of Arkansas but
regardless he's phenomenal in the run
game and with that strength and a great
lower half body that I like you're not
gonna overpower this guy he can play
center he can play guard whatever it may
be I saw Alex Mack here okay and he's
one of the most athletic best centers
the exactly right I don't think there's
gonna be a scheme or a matchup on the
defensive line that's ever gonna be a
problem for Billy price if you tell me
that you have an Ohio State offensive
lineman that played all four years and
won the Rimington Trophy yeah that's
kind of a solid guideline and the only
reason he's still here is because a torn
peck suffered in training so that's why
is he fell a little bit but I saw him as
a Ryan Kelly type player and anyone who
remembers our draft when Ryan Kelly came
out of Alabama
I loved that kid who this guy named
Billy price I put a first-round grade on
him an a-plus I put a first-round grade
on him in September and put my pin down
just about scouting him yeah I give it a
I mean this is a position of need for
the Cincinnati Bengals and this guy is a
hell of a player like I said he can he's
got quicks to match up with the quick D
tackles he's got the power to match up
against the bigger defensive tackles the
only negative about the guy I wrote is
falls off blocks sometimes only because
he's trying to kill people he literally
has to dial it back in here but that's
the kind of guy I like I liked that too
Urban Meyer when asked about him said
I'm deeply indebted for his leadership
and play well guess what that's pretty
good that's pretty good since I need
bangles they got their interior lineman
for a very long time
we have ourselves a trade another one
the Ravens have traded back to the
Tennessee Titans they're gonna take care
of Landry
oh man yeah Wow and they need a pass
rusher badly what do you think we hear
them Connor
uh-oh I think it's rashon Evans oh I'd
be great with that too I think when you
look at Vrabel he I mean the way Evans I
think Bray Ville wanted van Dhiresh and
now he's gonna get Evans and Evans takes
all other hurt a veteran oh I don't know
yeah I heard yeah the Titans failed him
a lot of medical yeah the medical issue
so if you look at the pass rushers right
now Brian Iraq Poe and Derek Morgan yeah
both free agents after this both getting
a little older middle linebacker they
did lose Avery Williamson yeah and there
is kind of a hole there right now it's
Nate Palmer and Wesley Woodyard right we
got Dean Pease and Rashad Evans you're
Sean Evans is CJ Mosely so but the
question is if you're Dean Pease do you
want Terrell Suggs or CJ Mosely yeah
Harold Landry or Rashad Evans yeah I
know where is there a part of you they
don't need a corner I just wonder if
last year Harold Landry film was hurting
him like you know you listen we know he
wasn't a hundred percent healthy but
there's a number of coaches that look at
me when I say things like that they go
well yeah but does he open is he ever
gonna be the same guy that we saw off in
junior year or whatever mesozoic
variables Titans just jumped New England
yeah I know what he would have been
interested in Landry to or were Sean
Evans they both they might have
something that they're interested in
they wanted a linebacker in the country
last year they drool to myself good
we're at that point of the draft yeah at
that point we're since I've always been
holding my pee for three hours then
where I held it it got bad and now we're
right in that middle you're talking
about I gotta go yeah all right so
Titans what's your prediction this one I
really don't mind is Landry
you're gonna guess Landry I mean I just
I don't know anyway I'm gonna go because
of what you're saying about the Patriots
I feel like the Patriots wonderful Sean
Evans I feel I couldn't jump enough to
take Evans I would be as a person who
wants to live in Nashville as soon as
possible and be really I love Nashville
you're a cowboy hat what do you say
what was your guess he's guessing Landry
I'm guessing heavens what are you
guessing
I'm gonna go happens as well what do you
go in here Connor I'm going Evans I'm
sticking it up so in the terrain
Tennessee gave up a fourth and they got
back a six I'm shocked at the little
amount of pics that it's taking to move
up four or five spots I got the pic all
right Connor lay the wood humble brag I
was right
it's not about Evan that's a yeah wow
that was the first time that you were
wrong Miller
no I've been wrong I mean the first day
must have not texted him the answer that
had I tried to go in there was how he
waited move to jump new wing I think it
was we talked every Mach I saw had the
Patriots taking Rashad Evans at 23 the
biggest giveaway for me that the
Patriots liked Mershon Evans was mike
Mayock stop hundred lists mike Mayock
talks to Bill Belichick bill straightens
him out on who where he should rank
players and where Sean Evans was like
pick number three that was the 13 best
player in the draft does it go up so
bill likes Rashad Evans huh I mean I was
a giveaway it's very interesting that
they take rag now the center and Rashad
Evans and I feel like the Patriots like
both those are those guys without a
doubt yes well it's still it's a GM that
came from to England John Robinson I'm
gonna give this an a yeah same here
man where Sean Evans go into a Mike
Vrabel team that made the playoffs last
year and what's really funny is what
position did the Patriots absolutely
destroy in that game line back yes we
left that game when we went the
linebackers were just talking to each
other because they had no idea right and
Rashad Evans is a second-team all-sec
captain of Alabama are ready to go day
why exactly he's awesome man he's so
much better than Avery Williams he could
play if he can play off the edge even
man you're gonna be interesting he is
like yeah he's a he's a he's a really
impressive football player hey hey give
me camera five real quick the Patriots
are on the clock Lamar Jackson is there
is he the next town Brady that's a
cardinal noise kiss Lamar Jackson John
Evans there's a good pick by the
Cardinals don't make that kind of noise
I was horrible
that's a dollar the birdfeeder as a
dolphin I think I'm right dolphins
Cardinals the Titans were picking behind
the Patriots and then they weren't maybe
they knew a little something and maybe
Vrabel had his eyes on a linebacker that
loves him rashon evans alabama this guy
just makes so much sense yeah and he
makes so many plays he was my number 20
player overall so a great value for the
Tennessee Titans he can play in the
middle of the field he could play coming
off the edge he's a do-it-all linebacker
and he is a twitch dub version of what
we're used to from Alabama and I know
people who liked him better than Rueben
foster when you put it all together
because there's no off field he's just
as safe as they come at linebacker and
Red Bulls probably saw a little bit of
himself in this guy because he really
can be a difference maker weak side
strong side Mike anywhere you put him
this is a Titans team that was second in
the NFC AFC South they went to the
playoffs can this guy take him to the
next step yeah he certainly can he's a
player that has zero weakness I mean and
he can do anything middle linebacker oh
you wanted to play outside linebacker
for a game whatever it may be he's gonna
be able to do that if you want to put
him in and rush him off the edge a
little bit he did that at Alabama as
well but he's a true middle linebacker
who can run sideline to sideline he's
been coached well he's gonna understand
this scheme Dean P's three four type of
scheme and he's gonna be phenomenal and
past coverage as well I was really
impressed with the kid man he's athletic
he can get off blocks he's physical like
I said there's no weakness to him at all
what grade do you give him now I give it
an A I think he is a plug-and-play
starter and we're seeing Mike Vrabel
really put his stamp on this team the
toughness that they he wants on defense
Evans is smart he's athletic I compared
him to Alec Ogletree I think he could be
a little better than that because he's
so explosive yeah I see that Alec Cole
the tree I'm giving a as well I mean
this was a huge position of need for a
team that's coached by an ex middle
linebacker that played in this similar
scheme so he understands what this is
all about Evans I looked at it Dean
Pease a deep D coordinator of the gari I
go
this is CJ Mosley who he had in
Baltimore
this kind of player he could be in a few
Pro Bowl certainly the Titans lost
Sylvester Williams Avery Williamson and
Bryce McCain and they got Benny Logan
Rashad Evans and Malcom Butler yet the
Titans are a lot better yeah and they
made the playoffs last year for Sean
Evans Manning the middle for years to
come any chance they take I just still
can't believe I'm looking at number one
Baker Mayfield it's popping up with a
sign that the Browns left with Baker
Mayfield and Denzel wort and they could
have had say Kwan Berkeley and Josh
Allen like or or sand Arnold and say or
Bradley chub and they left with Baker
Mayfield and Denzel Ward it's just
sometimes it doesn't matter where the
numbers are yeah just got a look at the
players you got and you get to
undersized guys it's interesting it is
alright we're gonna go to Connor here
first
what is your Patriots prediction man I
think Josh Jackson you think Josh Jack
they definitely I think they'll look for
a corner I think they'll look for a guy
with ball skills and length I mean he's
got the perfect bill like what about
Harold Landry but guys I'm just gonna
say this with the Josh Jackson he
doesn't play man-to-man that would be my
one issue everything Patriots that play
a lot of mana man yeah that would be my
one issue with that it's probably why
we've seen him slide further than a lot
of people I think you do specific they
you know this day and age the way the
league is right now
you know with the rules the way they are
if you can't play to man-to-man on 3rd
and 6 or less you're gonna be in deep
trap Andy is there any chance that the
the Patriots knowing that Gronk could
retire soon go ahead and Hurst here I
like it first ok it certainly could fit
yes there was there any chance that they
lost Nate's older they go at Connor
Williams here tackle out of Texas he
doesn't seem to fit in them very well I
mean I don't know he's a super athlete
you got Dante's scar neck you know I
don't know you know I don't know I don't
know if he'd be their type of tackle
they they want to know they want a
neanderthal attack and what I think they
won eight they want cold Miller's Nate
solders they want you know Sebastian
volmers guys that are six eight Connor
Williams is like six five one three
300 right yeah is there any chance they
go at Eyvind Brian here gosh he would
fit what they want to do they load it up
in free agency though on the d-line rate
did get dementia and their day I'm
Malcolm Brown they have Adrienne
Claiborne who I think that's what Ava
and Brian what kind of be that role I
will say though Danny Shelton Malcolm
Brown both free agents after the year
Trey flowers is a free agent of the year
and a girl Landry is sitting I know and
this is New England which is scouts
Boston all the time I mean they're all
over Boston and it could be maybe Lamar
Jackson he's not on the phone he's on
the phone it's he's looking around he
has no idea what he's like I don't know
I never bought that talk so if we're
gonna go the Patriots right now let's
say they go corner
Panthers are next Calvin Ridley falling
into their lap then the Ravens come back
at 25 that's where I think the more that
could be that's probably more Jack
listen all they got to do they can't
they can't go farther than 29 the Ravens
though cuz the Jack Seville gets Lamar
Jackson the jack the Jags I was the
Jaguars to trade up get Lamar just many
people says he doesn't that's what we
reckon the NFL well I know what that
sound means that means we're going to
the bulging bye
I love this line it is hope is James day
and I love this player it's pregnant
Isaiah win okay I got a guy that you
know he's like you said Sims n Miller
this could be a Pro Bowl guard right
well I've talked to some teams that do
think he can do terrible tackle yeah I
see it I've been left tackle I don't
think he will I think the guys you know
again they have guys on the roster
Marcus cannon we're missing the other
guy happen Antonio Garcia wore Antonio
Garcia
they got Jason he he and Chuck Mason
that's actually who I compare him to I
mean that would be an unbelievable run
game guard combo I mean this kids a
shock Mason Isiah win
Isiah win so maybe they're uh Dhoni did
have issues you're right about that we
can't forget that
Dooney had issues during the year he was
really a liability through most of the
years he did not play up to the ability
I liked Chef Mason but you guys never
had the suit
right center let's check Mason get by uh
Brandon growl how do you think on greats
guys Oh
let's give it let me just think of what
else would they really think this many
interior offensive linemen going in a
row here Frank rag now at twenty Billy
price at twenty one as a win at twenty
three we're in I rarely go a - Connor oh
I'm gonna be with myself guard grades
again it's off greater yeah Sims you'll
love this he was the number one
offensive line recruit in the state of
Florida means you know I like man and
now we have Carolina it's interesting so
don't he's listed so you guys talk about
wanting a Neanderthal he's a six to
tackle yeah I know that's why I don't
think he's a tackle I think he will be
moved to guard I really know who do they
put Lee you're gonna get thrown me out
of there they're gonna get through the
out of there let a drienne Waddell and
cannon and and really the guy that we
were just talking about Garcia they love
Garcia really
he had medical issues but they love him
that'll be their interior with David
Andrews I think it would be David
Andrews Shaq Mason and Isaiah win yeah
and then where are they putting Garcia
Garcia is gonna be a tackle tackle he's
six six he's their guy guess what Tom
Brady's protected for these last waiting
years let's do Isaiah win to the
Patriots this is by the way the pick
they got in the Brandon cooks trade the
Patriots are really good at addressing
important positions they got the 23rd
pick from trading Brandon cooks they
didn't need the receiver but they turn
that into Isaiah win a punishing Center
offensive lineman that's gonna go there
the guard and now the sudden this
Patriots lines looking pretty dumped it
does look pretty good and I had I say a
win ranked number 29 overall played left
tackle at Georgia freakishly long arms
great in the run game I think he does
kick inside to left guard for the
Patriots run James gonna look better
pass protections gonna look better and
and he is a dude anytime you talk to
coaches at Georgia they raved about team
first good athlete very productive
playing left tackle so I like this pick
a lot and the value definitely was there
especially after we saw guys like where
Sean Evans late band rush come right off
the board yeah you know Patriots better
than a lot of people what do you think
about him in that Cisco I think he fits
the system I don't think there's any way
he
plays left tackle like I think they
could get away with it if they needed to
through injury but this guy is a
prototypical guard I just don't think
he's a big enough human for them to put
him in that tackle knowing the Patriots
scouting system but man the guy is
unbelievable you want to talk about a
road grader in the run game he can move
people out of the way in fact his
negative is really that he's like a
little too aggressive like we've talked
about with other offensive linemen where
he falls off but yes it's like a cool
heo Somali but not as big I wrote a lot
like a layout Lyle Collins who plays on
the Dallas Cowboys but extremely
impressed with this guy is to be able to
do all the spatial things that the
Patriots need the screens all that stuff
type the wide receiver screens he's
gonna be able to get out there and block
and lead the way great for him at 23
yeah I gave it a B+ I think he can play
guard I think you could play Center
think you can get him in a lot of
different spots so it is a smart pick
and I'm often critical of Bill Belichick
the general manager yeah he got this one
right yeah I know I mean Bill Belichick
the general manager gets saved by Bill
Belichick the coach a lot I'm going to
give this an a though because this
offensive line a - sorry this offensive
line was below average last year it just
was not good enough Tom Brady got hit
way to much the run game was
inconsistent this is gonna give them a
true you know bonafide legit top-tier
guard in the middle that's gonna help
out in a lot of ways they're improving
their old line good for that lost
soldier they lost Caverns plumbing and
don't forget this we're talking about
paranoia Shaq Mason Shaq Mason's a free
agent after this year right so it could
be stocking up it could also be
inventory Isaiah win the pick for the
Patriots number 23
Calvin Ridley 100% 24 I mean that's what
I would think I could see corner as well
do this I know they just gave him a mini
extension do they start to look Greg
Olson I know like hey purses right now
got her I know I know
oh I've thought about all those and the
corner thing I thought - I just go damn
you know we don't see the banners right
they don't really seem to do that so her
knee does a little more than yeah he
probably does more than the past regime
sure because their corners men are James
Bradbury Kevon Seymour Captain Marlon
Cornell der I would just take Isaiah
Oliver here and be done with it but you
would take him over one of these wide
receivers because right now these are
the starting libraries and the receivers
at Carolina Panthers Torrey Smith Devin
Funchess Tamir bird Russell Shepherd
Curtis Samuel Jarius right I mean I
didn't hear the Panthers tweeted they're
treating uh from the team account yeah I
just saw it Oh
people suck on Twitter never mind all
right how about these guys Harold Landry
still somehow on the board we're
thinking this is because of his last
year yeah just the interim maybe there's
something about more medical to it then
we don't know art well let me ask you
this
Julius Peppers getting up there in age
Mario Edison not really a pass rusher I
don't know where the pass rush is coming
is there any chance that maybe Harold
Landry's the guy no I don't know like
were you thinking you heard Calvin
Ridley I I didn't hear it I just think
that makes a lot of sense Seaford
they need a safe pick and receiver they
got to give Cam Newton some weapons at
some I actually agree you know I mean
he's a safe pick he's not the most
explosive he's not the best but he's
gonna be polished ready to go good about
a run out of the corner to where you
could get a corner and run I exactly is
no reason that a team with Cam Newton at
quarterback should have been 28th in the
NFL in passing offense I know there's
gonna be a ding and I know we're going
to Connor we have a little rule at
bleacher report at the NFL desk where if
you get chaps or fooled you have to wear
the hat you have to wear the hat
and Miller gear but Miller just got I
did he got played so bring me that he's
got yeah gosh it's good walked by I
don't know some idiot on Twitter so yeah
if you believe Twitter rumors this
happened to me a few years ago we've all
been a little can we get it I was
adjusting give my camera there alright
so we got the pig looking like Bob the
baby don't look at the TV Sims alright I
want it's a wide receiver DJ more it's
not Calvin Ridley it's DJ more DJ more
for that Maryland I love it
do I take this I just made money betting
on DJ more - yes what do you think it
for great I'll give it a B how dare you
dare he took the hat off well I have to
do a real video are you gonna do it in
the video I don't know what the rule is
no do it after the video yeah forget the
video goes on BR the BR app if you don't
have it you're a loser that's the model
right or if you believe people when I
say B if you know the BR app use you
like traditional networks telling you
what to believe and you're not a
free-thinking independent individual and
you should probably go eat McDonald's
because it's finally a guy for Cam
Newton that can make a play with the
ball in his hands
definitely yeah I'm just glad that he's
got a weapon around him he from
Philadelphia yeah that's right he is
from Philadelphia but he's mean the I
think he's it's the athlete that excites
me here that's what really excites me I
mean and also look Calvin released 23 DG
Morse 21 yeah I don't like older guys
excelling against young kids in college
it's my Kelvin Benjamin indeed and
Calvin Ridley he's older and he can't do
the things DJ Morecambe in the pool you
watched one play of DJ more and you said
I like him better than Calvin Ridley
remember that yeah you pulled up the
film and said he just did something that
Calvin really didn't I never saw him do
right exactly right they got a little
Steve Smith here that's right it's a
good way to pass a it awesome let's do a
video
there's no reason that a team with Cam
Newton should be 28th and passing
offense and I'll tell you what they've
lost Kelvin Benjamin over the years
they've been relying on people like
Curtis Samuel no more
DJ Moore is what we call an explosive
athlete 21 year old out of Maryland what
are they getting at pick number 25 III
said right before we started filming
they're getting a little Steve Smith
here I mean he's aggressive with the
ball in his hands he's a powerful runner
in the open field he's an elite player
after the catch I think the best in this
class he'd wins a ball in his hands he
does his burst is above average he can
run pass coverage he has a thick frame
on a 511 body my biggest concerns with
him where I thought his routes were
really lazy at times and he was probably
quicker than fast but run some slants
dude make make life easy for Cam Newton
very productive I do like him a lot yeah
listen I think those problems are like
Sean Davis of we saw a few years ago to
Maryland it's more coaching than the
athlete I have no problem for two and
had a six five six nine five three cone
drill if somebody teaches him how to run
routes he's gonna do it this guy has
superstar traits he is numbers I mean
they're phenomenal with the ball in his
hand he is the best receiver in the
draft it's not even close I'll say this
for a guy that's six foot two he is
unbelievable at the 50-50 ball throwing
back shoulders he just plucks the ball
out of the air he has an attitude I like
I look at him like Percy Harvin
he played running back in Maryland -
he's Percy Harvin ish except I think
he's a better route or a better wide
receiver than Percy Harvin was coming
out a fourth or what you crazy foul no I
gave it a beat I like him a lot as a
player I think again he is an explosive
route runner he's gonna help Cam Newton
I liked Calvin Ridley a little better
but I get go with the younger guy
because they are pretty similar I had an
early ran too great on him so to get him
here where they did it 24 is a pretty
good value yeah okay I'm gonna go a plus
here I mean there you go yeah I know
we're different here these men Turner is
gonna like this is one of my man crushes
of the draft this is one of my favorite
players in the whole a drop yes I do
think they're gonna they're gonna be
able to use him in so many different
ways you know think about them almost
like a Tyree kilij but a little bit
bigger of a man the acceleration on this
kid just catch the ball and then goes
yeah double moves and it's a Panthers
north turner double move it's like we
I'm telling you the guy has a chance to
be a superstar solving those highlights
he was rockin the one at Maryland you
know he got it from Stefon Diggs I don't
know could be something he might be the
number one receiver for the Carolina
Panthers next season Josh Hendrick
didn't give him one bendrix ever hear
going maryland talk this is amazing
Ravens are up josh is like I'll probably
leave after pick five Ravens is this
gonna be Lamar Jackson I know Harold
Landry
I know get your next Terrell Suggs or
your christen a cat lows of this pick I
feel like edges yeah like the Bowser Tim
Williams right Tim William right with
show knows if he's just hell I know what
happens I'm gonna neat and Jolly
Ranchers ourselves a Darius Smith they
have Korea they rent urban is a Darius
Smith Terrell Suggs
all free agents after this right so it's
kind of coming to an end with some of
the right herbs not even a real pastor
sure he's a fine I'm just talking about
guys that might I mean Carl Davis is
coming up on the contract but Brian
would make sense if there David Lyfe
definitely make sense Haven Brian looks
like a raven yeah yeah he would he's not
like the bird but like some guy that
shite in makes them yeah yeah I'll be
honest that Max Williams guy hasn't
really done anything this could be
hating her this is the Ravens are a team
that you look at their roster and their
secondary is finally set like their
secondary sucked for years and now it's
good but now the rest of their team has
fallen apart so the question is do you
go with the edge rusher or do you
completely change the franchise and
gollum our guys there is definite legit
love for Lamar Jackson on this full page
sign we're talking about RG 3 so he's
probably gonna take of early because
he's from Alabama Alabama
well no but I thought that was a
possibility you spent no no it's not
Willie send it right you're right
they're not going for addressing you're
not I'm not there very few times where I
get to tell Sims he's wrong at field and
I'm looking at Lamar he's not on the
phone so damn hey you know what if Lamar
Lamar could go to the see Steelers at 28
or the Jaguars at 29 and I'm loving life
yes Lamar Jackson on the jet
is the best thing for the sims and left
go bug instantly is it is selfishly it
is the best thing it's the best this
would be one of the best places for more
Jax Ryan it's gonna go put the hat back
on okay
give me the damn hat I fall for it no
God that it's tight you look ridiculous
child yeah I know it's a huge orange hat
I feel like that's like on New York City
biggie watch out here there's a crane
over the top be careful though my dad
would be so proud
the Ravens are under construction yeah
it's better than the shaped head that
was gonna do it quick William soon we go
to a commercial break yeah so I'm seeing
one but not buying into it just yeah
okay Connor tell us can you tell us
it'll it'll surprise you yeah well it's
a good football player but it'll still
surprise me okay
hey John Ben's defense yep where look at
my big board oh this is your best
impersonation see that's why I didn't
trust it are we right about any line I'm
getting some really now it's offensive
I'm ignoring the hand they pick you do
look like you're like you know like I
count from Transylvania that has a raven
stuck up in the tower
all right the message here's the thing
it was not defense that person was wrong
I should wear the hat okay you should
good I think it's time its Hayden Hearst
it's Williams train is out of here I
just want to give a shout out to John
quark who lost a bet to me because he
thought max was gonna be good you're an
idiot
Wow oh ma stay so you're gonna draft an
old people this kid's gonna be 25 is it
rookie Heena well I hope you didn't get
the yips hole he had the yips he was a
minor league baseball player he got a
big old contract to play for the Pirates
organization his story is great but he
comes out there he's a heck of a tight
end yeah really is he's soul raids we
could make fun of his oh I'll give it a
b-plus damn so does this mean that
Harold Lane is just gonna fall to the
Falcons I'm gonna go ahead Conner
oh absolutely oh absolutely goes I'm the
this is the softest grades I've ever
given this year it was yeah I think the
number one overall pick was you're my
meanest more meanest harsh is great they
didn't hate Oklahoma what heck did you
make it boomer sooner
oh what grade did you give here don't
even know what that means
we got a a from Sims and a B+ from
Miller I it's it's I don't really know
either it's all right let's do it Hayden
Hearst I got respect for you though I'm
in there huh oh you Hall of Fame more
than the Lu players getting sacked the
Roy Williams hits everywhere damn guy a
baseball prodigy with a 95 mile-per-hour
fast Falls going to Baltimore in 82 the
Orioles it's to the Ravens Hayden her
South Carolina tight end they need
another weapon out there they try to
find one a max Williams wasn't the guy
what are they getting in Hayden her I
think they're getting a three down tied
in someone who is fierce after the catch
like you said a little bit of an older
prospect but he can dominate up the seam
like we see here and I I think there's
still some potential that he can tap
into because he's learning the
intricacies of the position he'll block
for you I think he's more of an h-back
than a true inline tight end so you are
gonna move him around get him out in
space where he can just go be an athlete
make plays so we had heard all along
they were gonna go pass catch her
whether it was receiver her tight end
and they get an upside prospect here
yeah I love this kid I really do I mean
I was just pleasantly pleasantly
surprised when I watched in my melt film
first of all he can do everything
Miller's right I mean really he can be
traditional tight end he could be H back
he can line up at fullback he can line
up a slot receiver he will try to kill
you when he blocks you that's what I
like about him he is fearless blocker
that fits what the Baltimore Ravens want
to do they want to be a balanced
football team but yes he's a good route
runner he's a good athlete he's very
good with the ball in his hand left go I
mean they throw him shuffle passes they
give him speed sweeps in South Carolina
and he makes things happen with the ball
in his hand Marty morning wag the rose
he has always been a guy that likes that
athletic tight end and this is a team I
mentioned max Williams he's a free agent
after this year maybe it's time to move
on do you think about grade wise no I
gave it a B+ I do like him a lot I think
can play any of those tight end
alignments that you can envision for him
and he is still getting better so you
get the best three down tight in in this
entire class they're gonna try to help
Joe Flacco out I'm glad they didn't go
quarterback here I want to see them load
up they have a good defense yeah they've
paid some receivers let's see what they
can good I hear that all of that I think
I'm given an A Hayden Hurst I mean this
is a position of need for the Baltimore
Ravens I mean of course yes they want to
run the ball they want to be aggressive
down the middle of the field with Joe
Flacco so he fits it there's nothing not
to like about this kid I think he's
really kind of a can't-miss prospect
altogether I looked at him and I said
he's very much like Dallas Clark to me
hmm
Peyton Manning's old teammate that's
what I looked at him it's like and
hopefully he can turn to turn that out
Hayden her South Carolina athlete at
tight end gonna try and open up the
middle for Joe Flacco and the Ravens
all right the pick is in for the Falcons
I'm gonna go with Miller I think it
Steve and Brian I mean I feel like this
is like made for them the easiest pick
ever should be you agreeing with us
Connor I know the pick so it's ruined I
would have said tape and Brian oh no
it's not it is not they're going they're
going Howard Landry already half they're
not going Harald Lane all right I'm
gonna guess Alice Connor
yeah they are now going alright I'm
gonna say that they're actually going
James Daniels they are not going James
Daniel although I do like that pick
Thank You angry they're going Calvin
Ridley they are oh well thank you leo
what the hell was that whole thing I
don't know I'm just glad I know they're
naked all of his social media they were
like he's leaving Atlanta I don't know I
know maybe it's the fact that they have
Mohamed Sanu Justin Hardy and Justin
Hardy hasn't really turned into anything
right and maybe they're blaming
sarkeesian's lack of offensive
creativity on the lack of wide receiver
well and sinew is limited in some of the
things he can do as well we'll say this
though Nick Saban went to Alabama and
got three wide receivers to go in the
first round
Julio Jones Amari Cooper and now Calvin
Ridley
two of them are on the same team Calvin
Ridley and Julio Jones daily dope yeah
that is pretty dope
Adam Schefter tweeted one of the
greatest moments in NFL draft history is
coming up soon don't want to miss it
be memorable well that's the Jaguars
taking Lamar Jackson or it's the chicken
Griffin in the first round
Wow I love them on the Seahawks with his
brother alright so Calvin Ridley though
what is your grade for getting him it I
give it an A+ A+ you know Calvin really
is crying on TV that's nice what do you
think of Sims what you're great I'm
gonna give it just a name - he will be
24 in the season I want to say one other
thing there sometimes you read about
kids he grew up in the foster care
system with his three brothers and his
after his father was deported to Guyana
alright this is a guy that's been
through a ton of stuff went to Alabama
played for Nick Saban won national
championships played with a running back
as his quarterback and is now going to
be with Julio Jones in Atlanta yeah
that's awesome it's also cool he gets to
go play for Atlanta his brother plays
for Georgia right now
no that's pretty family together I mean
you go through the foster care system
and you're afraid it means you got all
these different places and now you're
all in the same spot that's really cool
all right let's do Calvin Ridley to
Atlanta and their eighth ranked passing
offense one of the best moves in the
history of the Atlanta Falcons was
getting a wide receiver from Alabama
named Julio Jones well some how many
perceived as the top wide receiver in
this draft from Alabama Falls to them at
26 Calvin Ridley I feel like this is
fouled gold it is it really is and this
is a true best player available pick for
the Falcons I thought they were gonna go
D line here Ridley slips I think he was
the best overall receiver in the draft a
great route runner silky smooth on
braking routes he's not the biggest guy
but four four three speed and what he's
able to do on braking routes he's gonna
open up that offense and yeah they have
a lot of depth of receiver but I think
he could be a difference maker on
underneath he could play in the slot he
has the right body for that he's gonna
be a tremendous playmaker so sir Keegan
connection here - well I don't know if
they're Bowl yeah there's a little bit
cuz he played the coach the officer yeah
so you know
you're right I didn't even think of that
left go but certainly knows him hey this
guy's already game day one right away I
mean there's no doubt about that is
ready he's the most polished wide
receiver in the draft yes was he my
favorite receiver no but there's really
nothing to look at him and go oh I don't
like that part of them I just don't
think he's gonna be the most explosive
yards after catch type of guy but he's
gonna be able to win on the outside
you're gonna be scared of him going deep
via he's gonna be able to play the slot
he's they catch the ball over the middle
so again for an offense that's kind of
needs a guy that can help them right now
it makes sense what you're great for
this but I gave it an A+ I I do like
that you recognize a strength when you
got to a Super Bowl it was with a great
offense Matt Ryan extend that window and
with Julio Jones deleting everything on
Twitter and makes you wonder how long
he's gonna be in Atlanta anyway I'm
gonna go a - I like the player there's
some defensive guys on the board that I
think I would have considered with them
I mean this is the Falcons there's no
Don Terry PO there was Haven Brian on
the board Harold Landry's on the board
this is the Falcons I mean I they want
pass rushers I'm a little surprised they
went this route for such a successful
offense even with all of the lack of
quarterback play this guy caught a pass
in all 44 games yes three seasons he's
polished and at this point of the draft
it's a heck of a finite Lana got
themselves a good one in Calvin with me
Seahawks are on the board is Harold
Landry a thing I mean I would think so
Devon or Darius guys see on Jordan cliff
Averill Marcus Smith and Frank Clark are
all free agents after the season right
my goodness
right it's an exodus of pass rushers yes
I don't know if they're gonna rely on
the Barkevious Mingo but I think if you
match up Frank Clark jarran Reed
they got Shamar Stephens and I just
think Harold Landry is kind of that
guinea Josh Jackson being a really good
fit here too
yes Josh Jackson certainly would fit
their scheme he would definitely I this
is a lot of people playing for them I
yes they could do Taven Brian -
certainly I mean I look at him what
about Connor Williams for them yeah I
mean they could go off something so is
it Whelan and we're going to talk about
Seattle's offensive line all the time
and you got Connor Williams sitting
there they they have so many will James
Daniel what's different this years they
let Tom Cable make their offensive line
picks in the past and he's gone I mean
they completely revamp this let's play
this against that leave that big board
up there who could they go with that
would really upset you not that you
would like that you go this was
unnecessary I don't even know of those
guys yeah none I think all those guys
would be a good fit there they have a
lot more needs than people real they're
decimated yeah I mean that they need to
rebuild the secondary let me read the
list of guys that are no longer on the
seahawks from last year Paul Richardson
Luke Wilson Jimmy Graham Sheldon
Richardson Michael Bennett Richard
Sherman Jeremy Lane 2 Sean shed Thomas
Rawls all of those guys left this
offseason they got rid of everybody what
do you think's their biggest need Sims
how do you pick a problem it's it's it's
so tough I mean it's just
cliff cliff cliff April's injury issue
kam chancellor we don't know where he's
right
right so you did look at that right away
offensive line certainly always is an
issue Connor what do you thinking the
problem is Malik McDowell wet the last
second-round pick
absolute dud nothing I mean he gotten
that ATV accident and that forced them
to trade their second round or
Richardson but now he's gone so it's a
problem becoming a revolving door and
why this is why Taemin Brian that is why
taping Brian makes so much sense because
he can be that 3/5 very similar guy to
Sheldon Richardson yeah I'll say this if
your interior D line is jaren Reed and
Taven Bryant it's a heck of a
competition so we should talk about how
poorly they played the Sheldon
Richardson deal by the way make that
tray and give up Jermaine Kearse because
the Jets would have been able to come
get Sam Donald tonight if it wasn't for
that trait so they got Jermaine Kearse
and were able to go get Sam Donald
because they trained at Sheldon
Richardson who wasn't even good in
Seattle and isn't even there oh they
took that pick and flipped it to him up
to three hey they I know they offered
Richardson pretty good money though I
mean he decided he wanted to go on a
one-year better himself that ideal yeah
I would rather play for Minnesota - yeah
right now your needs met it really could
be a it could be d tackle it could be
alive this is anything but quarterback
yeah really it could be you know I'm
gonna go tape and Brian what are you
guys going I mean I don't know I haven't
seen the pic and they gave me the noise
but I don't have the I don't have the
pic yet I don't know maybe says on TV
the pic sent the Seahawks war room and
they're standing around like they got no
idea so I'm gonna go tape and Brian Sims
what are you going you know who still on
the board
Harold Landry will freaking Hernandez I
know I know he was always like a late
round okay I know you guys loved him and
I I do too bit he was always gonna be a
25 to 32 pic okay he's a throwback guy
he's sure yeah like short-armed a little
bit I love those guys yeah I'm gonna go
Harold Landry again there's mean I've
only said that four times this day you
guys are not gonna believe this pic I
had to ask
canvas they're in the control room three
times they looked like they didn't
believe the pic in the Seattle war room
they picked Rashad penny what yes
running back from San Diego State Rashad
round pick brush on penny I don't think
read with that but I'm still shocked he
was the thirties the third best running
back in the draft for me
I would go Berkeley Michelle Rashad
penny but not right here this thing I've
ever heard on a team that has that many
holes this is so gonna take a running
back well the funny thing is is like
they have a plethora of running backs
Carson CJ Prosise JD mckissick Mike
Davis yes and you're gonna draft a guy
that's he's pretty good I like in the
draft we get excited right you get a
great player and you get super pumped
and sometimes a team drafts a guy and
you go the hell is running things there
Miller great letter F take the cake F F
laughs I hate so bad
Sims I'm gonna guess you got value of
this pig oh I'm going worse than there's
a pen guy he's getting a they're getting
a dan they're getting a d-minus how was
that worse than enough it's not oh he
said I was gonna be - guys he's the
Mountain West Offensive Player of the
Year doesn't that congratulations
Jeffrey was great in that offense - Sims
you actually like this player more than
most this is a value problem for you
right it's just a value problem I like
the player a lot like I said I would go
Berkeley Michelle Rashad penny yeah but
let's play a game
yes rather of Harold Landry yes of
course that looks like Foghorn Leghorn
of course not no lower-body it's not the
most beautiful thing in the world
they passed up Haven Brian Harold Landry
all of the cornerbacks all of the tight
end prospects though all of the
offensive linemen and they're
high-fiving each other Seattle wanted to
change it they wanted to get rid all
these loudmouth guys and change the
culture if the culture you're changing
to is drafting Rashad pending over all
these guys you messed up let's do a
video though this one should be good
if I would have told Seahawks fans that
you could trade down multiple times and
you're sitting there with guys like
Harold Landry and tave and Brian you're
sitting there going this is a dream
scenario taking a running back with that
pick
I don't think factored in especially
when like Sony Michele still on the
board so what do you make of a shot
Petie at this I tell you left oh I'm so
happy right now
because I'm a 49ers fan I have no idea
what the Seahawks are doing this was the
eighth best running back on my board Wow
we've talked about this is one of the
best running back classes of all time
and you're gonna take a second to third
round player in the first round over
Darius guys over Sony Michele over carry
on Johnson over Nick Chubb over all the
guys who idea how to do it he doesn't
even have great vision I know the stats
look amazing congratulations Donnell
pumphrey looked good in that offense man
I hope I'm wrong because I I do know you
don't know I I'm good with this because
I think this is the worst pick of the
draft well I mean it's crazy to pick a
running back right here I would agree
with that I just didn't expect it does
lose show me Michelle on the board but I
will disagree with everything else you
said in that statement okay this guy is
the third best running back in the draft
he is special
he has got special feet you can't tackle
them one-on-one and nobody can catch him
and he can be a bell cow he's 511 220
it's not the most perfect body I
understand this not exactly what we
always usually look at it running back
but the film speaks for itself
I really like this kid I just don't like
him at the end of the first how can you
draft a running back when you don't have
an offensive line how can you or a
defensive line or cornerbacks what grade
you given this pick it this is an F and
that's because they won't let me go
lower well you give a d-minus no I gave
him an F I said F okay - but ya know it
was an F - because it's just a bad pick
on every level the values wrong the need
is wrong I don't even like the scheme
fit that much hmm I'm giving it a bad
grade okay I gave the d-minus but I'm
just gonna say I really like this player
I just don't know if it was necessary to
take him right now when you have other
needs on your football team that are
pressing certainly more pressing than
running
but man I will say the guy has chance to
be a special running back in the NFL I
think they want to redo it I thought it
was good I'm never gonna be able to
recreate the anger bro that was that was
okay why'd you want to redo it yeah but
who cares
oh the grade I definitely said F though
yeah right
do you put all right guys people
listening out there this is on the
control room if you notice we're one
take Timmy's damn all right well the
Steelers pick is in is that Harold
Landry is that Taven Bryant I give up is
it Lamar Jackson oh dude I would love
Lamar Jackson replace Ben Roethlisberger
I heard they were taking his safety
the Seahawks traded down multiple times
they had a number of great defensive
players offensive linemen positions of
need they went a running back from the
Mountain West Conference Rashad penny
what do you think Niners fan I want to
tell you something left oh I'm so happy
right now because I'm a Niners fan I
don't know what they're doing drafting
the eight best running back in the class
at the end of the first run you don't
have a no line you don't have receivers
you don't have a secondary you know have
a D line your rosters falling apart
you're a drafter running back this is
such a luxury pick this used to be one
of the best front office's in football
they have fallen apart I don't know what
John Schneider is thinking here what do
you think he's they go listen to this
guy okay he's not the number eight
running back in the in college this year
he was the third best running back in
the draft listen it's crazy I don't
expect them to do this certainly not but
I do like this player I wrote in my
notes he's the second best open field
runner I've seen in the draft at the
running back position he can run by
people he's got phenomenal feet you're
not gonna tackle him in the open field
so from that standpoint as a player I
really like him but my comparison to him
was a quicker footed Jordan Howard what
rounds is Jordan Howard dropped it in
the fourth round I believe so that is
where I'm confused by the ping I think
they're trying to get cute and like this
are alvin kamara he's someone who's
gonna help us on returns and out of the
backfield
it's just a luxury pick when they don't
have the roster to make this move you
could have gone so many different
directions Darius guys if you want to
running back so any Michelle if you want
to running back Nick Chubb carry on
Jonathan Walton it's an F F and they
won't let me go lower I would I'm giving
it a d-minus but just because of the
position of the pick and taking a
running back that grow running backs
grown trees this day and age sorry but
man I do like this player I really do it
I will not be shocked a few years from
now if he's not at the top of the NFL
rushing leaderboard I really won't be
hmm I'll tell you what though John
Schneider
he's gonna have to answer some questions
yes yes so we'll see what he did
Seahawks running back were shod penny at
27 I wrote in named Tyrell Edmond looks
like I wrote down before we did the
video he thought it'd be him
it just was Tyrell Edmonds safety
Virginia Tech yeah I love him I've told
you about it it remains brother if he
had been healthy slide he got flagged
for both knee and back issues a couple
of teams there you go so that explains
the current slide for Harold all right
so we're gonna do Terrell Edmonds for
people that are watching in the second
screen Ryan I get out that was the
moment that shifter was talking about
but I want to say walk with me
the Jaguars you're up now baby
every mock draft for months said Lamar
Jackson at 29 you are locked and loaded
at every position except for one
you got the seventieth best quarterback
you got the seventy-first best
quarterback backing him up play portals
and cody kessler you got Lamar freaking
Jackson
Leonard fournette don't mess this up
Terrell Emmons you're giving him a D
well man he got flagged medically from
everyone I talked to except for this
dealership we have two brothers ever
been drafted in the first round ever I
know you like him a lot I do I mean this
is about where I thought he might go
actually yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna
give him an a-minus
I wrote 33 to 50 I mean so this isn't
that far off I had him around alright
whenever you guys are ready okay so what
man two brothers going in the first
round how special is that man and I will
say see and Ryan shazier walk out there
without any damn special okay he was a
three-star cornerback recruited out of
high school so he's 21 and his brothers
19 man so you're not that big of a fan
what do you think about safety Hilty
just that's my so Tom at the versatility
because I look at the sailors and I see
Sean Davis and Morgan Burnett and I
didn't think safety was gonna be that
much of an if and Davis doesn't really
play the true state he more like a line
if I can nickel in the Box kind of go
this guy can go on top and let him roam
yeah all right let's do this video
because we need catch up cuz the Jaguars
pic is in and it better be freaking
Lamar Jackson
Steelers first pick is in they're a
they're a legacy organization they like
family well they took the second brother
in the first round the Edmonds Terrell
Edmonds I think everyone's heard about
Jermaine I need to learn about Toro yeah
well he is a versatile safety prospect
and someone I'll be it honest I did not
expect him to go first round I was not
expecting him to go second round because
shoulder issues an injury that shut him
down for 2017 was something that was
brought out to me often by teams of hey
this guy's flagged and this is a pretty
good safety class so where's the need to
get him I think he's more of like a
nickel line backer almost more than he
is he's that over the top safety he's a
guy you're gonna play in the box and
hope he can cover some tight ends III
really liked this kid you know yeah I'm
a huge fan of him I do think he's a true
safety free safety strong safety
combination he's gonna be able to get in
the Box like Miller talks about he's
extremely athletic I mean he can run you
can see four four seven forty one and
1/2 inch vertical that just tells you
how explosive he is but this is the
thing I was also impressed with let go
his ability to cover receivers now he
gets beat on film but that would go no
safety in college football was asked to
do what he was asked to do so yeah
there's a few times he gets beat but man
the athleticism the tackling everything
is there
I think he's top-notch this is about
where I thought he could go into the
first round top of the second what crazy
given have you give it a deep I thought
he was a third around player he is an
upside guy he's young I mean like it's
brother Tremaine he's a young guy
obviously there's NFL bloodlines but I
see someone who has to get better
awareness he has to come to balance
better as a tackler and I'm just not
sure he was a need for a team that has
Sean Davis I'm Morgan Burnett I don't
know where you're gonna guess is your
third safety he's gonna play the box
yeah well that's the way the NFL is
right now it's three safeties a little
bit for a lot of teams so I'm gonna go a
here I like this kid I told you there's
nothing I look at I wrote you know his
his movements his style of play reminds
me of Sean Taylor that's what I wrote
yeah I said I know he's not him but he's
one of the best safeties in the draft
and people are sleeping on this kid he
is a freak of nature and I think he's
got a bright future for the Steelers
sure the Steelers ago man we're gonna
need to keep you with the Patriots we
need more secondary guys and you got to
shut down tight ends he could be the guy
that however it's pretty special Edmunds
the second of two brothers in the first
round and he's going to the Steelers
legacy organization okay so I think I
think you could every Nexen reader that
would be insane oh yeah I forgetting
we're on air if Jacksonville doesn't
pick Lamar Jackson I'm very upset they
haven Brian and Brian I ever did he was
there he was the boy let's go to Connor
I do want to explain it after cuz I
think it makes a ton of sense it's
saving Brian yeah and here's what a lot
of people are missing Jacksonville is
gonna be like almost 40 million dollars
over the capital 2019 right and all that
money's tied up in Marshall Darius clays
cannibal Dante Fowler I believe his
fifth year yeah option if your office is
once again thinking in the two to three
year window it's all about class
Campbell in the future and this is but
you know what Jacksonville
really good at spotting talent at this
position yes and I guess the value was
just too good I'm just sitting here
going I can't believe Lamar Jackson he's
gonna follow the Patriots a31 doesn't
look like it's gonna happen
he's gonna go I know he's your guy and
like your room but I don't know it was
interesting to me though in the last two
weeks that's when all the first rounds
talk started and I got I got suckered
into it as well because everyone was
saying yeah he'll go first I'll go first
right and here we are with two three
picks left and he hasn't gone 6 5 291
we've been talking about Dave and Brian
now for like 15 picks what is haffley I
mean great athlete I think he's probably
about her 5 technique than his 3
technique yes and there were times like
his film was not great but you knew that
his first step was amazing and that he
was gonna test out out of the world we
had him on the podcast this week super
high character guy dad his Navy SEAL but
he's that's why he's so much about you
he's gonna have to be developed and I
think also one talking about what Conner
was saying about the the contracts
coming up that entire defense is really
signed until 2019 except for the guys
that you were mentioning with those huge
contracts and then also Jaguars for 21st
against the run last year yeah it's a
part of their defense that they were
amazed against the capacity they could
sack the quarterback but the big guys in
the middle you didn't always hit the big
performances out of them no but you know
don't forget remember would we always
used to say about them they play for the
past they try to be Belov for you with
the eighth guy at the line of scrimmage
but they're really playing past schemes
up front and in the secondary but so it
listen holy cow holy defensive line and
Jack oh my gosh hey hey hey as well yeah
I mean that well my last line was meant
I wrote if Kim D Chi it was a first
rounder than damn this kid goes before
the first pick so they're d-line right
now is yannick and gawk way Dante Fowler
a Bri Jones Marcel Darius Malik Jackson
coleus Campbell Mike Bennett and out
Dave and Brian that is insane
that's three defensive lines like Eagles
have a good - the Jaguars have three
defensive lines when you guys are ready
let's do this bad boy by the way I hope
Minnesota takes well Hernandez oh he's
perfect right so great well person will
Hernandez
like yeah they love that cookie cutter
what if I told you that the best defense
in the NFL said we need another horse
and they got one son of a Navy SEAL
David Brian a mauler out of Florida 65
to 90 what do you think about this guy
at this pick.i it's an upside pick he
was number 30 on my board overall
flashed at times on film tested much
better than he played so you don't need
him to play right away cuz you have all
those guys on the divine light class
Campbell like Marcel Darius he's gonna
be the future for that position gets to
stay in the home state of Florida and
he's just in two years he's gonna be so
much better than he is right now because
he's finally gonna come into his own
typically he's from taking these from
Wyoming but what do you who does he
remind you of a poor-man's JJ Watt I
mean that's what he he's impressive I am
I'm a huge fan of this kid I really am I
mean I am impressed with everything that
get off the explosion the ability to
shed blockers the ability to hold his
ground at 291 verse double teams it's
pretty good for a guy that size I mean
he's got big-time ability he's going to
be a handful he could be a three
technique he could be a five technique
if you want to play a different type of
defense damn he's athletic enough if you
said you know what we're playing a
running team this week we got to get
really big
you put Marcel Darius inside and Avery
Jones inside and then he got coleus and
Brian on the outside and say good luck
today I don't know what green do you
give a team now that has a spoil of
riches I gave it an A and I love the
value was great and I love the
Jacksonville's thinking ahead about
building this team they didn't panic and
draft a quarterback
they didn't panic and go interior
offensive line they got a guy that in
two to three years
formative JJ Watt I love it yeah yeah
that's how I saw and I'm with you I'm
giving an A as well because it is
thinking in the future and man the NFL
you just can't have enough good
defensive linemen right now I mean
especially if you're going to beat New
England and Tom Brady and the Patriots
cuz that's who's gonna be there at the
end this year you need to have pass
rushers like the Philadelphia Eagles
that can win the game at the end and
Jacksonville couldn't get to Tom Brady
in the fourth quarter to end that game
listen I should have taken the Marge axe
even Brian though building for the
future the Jaguars they just keep
getting bigger and badder like Vikings
with a great pic Minnesota taking one of
my favorite players in the journey to
deliver it to Connor Mike use you see it
Mike you take another corner they are
just he's just doing Cincinnati hi just
gonna stack corners yes academic so the
Vikings take UCF corner Mike Hughes by
the way you can't call it Central
Florida they get mad so they have really
they have three first-round corners and
a second-round corner trae Waynes Xavier
Rhodes McKenzie Alexander and Mike
Hughes yes three first I mean we want to
talk about this guy's closer to Denzel
Ward than people are ready all right so
why did he last this long when he was at
North Carolina originally he was accused
of sexual assault right a + got kicked
at dismissed suspended dismissed ended
up a Garden City can you get charged to
do charges Plus no charges no charges
okay all right and then when you're UCF
so he's like a one-year wonder but he is
a great return man mmm sticky corner and
he will talk about it on the video but
he's very good I know this I think this
was Simms his favorite corner it was the
first round is almost over
I know it kind of went fast but it's
it's 11:30 so I didn't go that fast
never mind you like to speak a lot I do
man I think this kid is I think it's the
man-to-man cover corner yeah I agree
in the draft and you know what that
wrote the return thing Marcus Cheryl's
is a don't do that
Marcus Charles is a free agent after the
season so he could take over the
returning duties as well right he's
gonna be if you they want to put him a
punt returner he is gonna be in the
conversation pretty crazy at that the
the Jaguars the Vikings just improved
their defenses they had and unlike the
Vikings really going to use the card
they have up your butt Jobu pics yeah
they can just go we could pick the best
player available he reminded me so much
of Pacman Jones yeah a little bit big
that but yep yep
Vikings got to the NFC Championship game
and they really get there on defense and
they add a guy that probably shouldn't
have been there at 30 some extenuating
circumstances in his past but Mike
Hughes an athlete at a UCF athlete at a
UCF one of the best corners in the class
probably the best return man in the
class as well yeah there were some off
field things that's why he's still here
but he is a sticky cover man he is tough
at the line of scrimmage plays with an
attitude I add him ranked as the number
26 overall player so the value is
definitely there and that's factoring in
some of those all field issues that
teams were a little concerned about kind
of a one-year wonder a UCF did the JUCO
kid before that yeah but he was dynamite
this year he nobody gets open against
this kid this is my favorite yeah it's
my favorite corner in the draft this is
he's the best pure man-to-man cover
corner for me and the draft his ability
to jam receivers at the line of
scrimmage turn and run break on the ball
he doesn't give the receiver in the
quarter bag anything he fights to get
the ball out of there he is phenomenal
in that standpoint tough as hell gonna
talk crap and you know what else they
does he is all over the field he Hawks
anybody if you think you're gonna run
for a 70 yard touchdown with him on the
field Wow good luck cuz he's gonna come
get you look at the committee havior
roads and him and then trae Waynes
running all over the pits insane when I
think he'll probably play in the slot oh
I gave it an A+ not only is he gonna
help a defense that's already one of the
best in the NFL he's gonna be a great
return man and like we always talked
about you got to compete with the top
teams in your conference in your
division he's gonna help them do that
yeah I'm given an A+ as well I mean this
is one of the best players in the draft
and here he is being taken at the end of
the first round by the Minnesota Vikings
for a team that's gonna be in the
Superbowl conversation but tough
physical the movements the twitchiness
you got to see him cover Cortland Sutton
big receiver out of SMU he got right up
in his face it was no problem he's a
star I think a lot of people were
expecting the Vikings to take an
interior offensive lineman there's still
a bunch left yeah I don't know if there
was a Mike Hughes left in this trap the
Vikings and that Mike Zimmer defense
they collect corners get in line
Vikings coming at you
all right is there we are patriots your
are let's guess let's guess yeah you
just guess Lamar let's go it's not
they're not trapped in a 13 wonder
liqueur back in New England they are
very comfortable with his thing I know
you wouldn't no idea I don't think he's
the pick though but no I don't think he
will be either they're our team that
they're trying to win the Super Bowl
this year too so it's it's it's a I know
they're thinking in the future but it's
like they are with George I guess it
guesses before it comes up on since
you're good I want Dallas got hurt here
but I don't think that's who it is a
good guess I'm gonna go Isaiah Oliver is
there a position its offense I'm not
giving you ants how mad are you as a
Jets fan oh we got Sam Donald uh-oh
I'm going Carlton Davis yeah I was all
right well in Davis earlier in the first
round they took Isaiah win and now they
took Sony Michelle the guy that he opens
up the way that Georgia rushing attack
right yeah okay so they lost the Ann
Lewis they all steal on Lewis they
signed Jeremy hill their current running
backs are Rex Burkhead
Jeremy hill James White I don't know
this pick I don't know if I like this
pick for that I do for me I either sees
a good player Connor but you lose
Malcolm Butler and you're sitting there
with an Isaiah Oliver on the board
well they find Jason McCourty I think
they're probably comfortable with that I
don't know if I am or Carlton Davis I to
be honest Sims has been pitching Carlton
Davis I love a perfect Patriots player
in terms of that scheme absolutely I
mean I see all over the place with them
I've seen some people that love them and
some don't
yeah they got a lot of running backs
though guys not any good ones this is
what they do but this listen I think
Sony Michelle was the second best
running back in this draft okay so
you're seeing some well I I would I
would have taken the under of three
running backs in the first I come I
don't know miss Allen Kimora man what
are we thinking on great you know I mean
watching him in the championship playoff
just give me a 2 seconds Connor and here
I come
uh I love it you know what if I'm Philly
who the hell do they take the first
round I say win Isaac Olivia mmm they
like Georgia I'm just trying to think
what else is out there that could have
totally been a so I had Connor Williams
Harold Landry Josh Jackson James Daniels
Isiah Oliver I think that the Eagles are
gonna take telesco dirt I can see that I
know I'm gonna go away by this Connor
all right we got Miller with an ace Sims
with an a-minus Gadar
I hope they go Carlton Davis that seems
really early for him who Carl's and
Davis you're saying yeah well we just
saw a shot penny going no joke exactly
the teams that have Carlton Davis's
there for one of their top five corners
yeah all right let's do Sony Michelle
this is one of the most exciting players
and the draft going to one of the best
teams the NFL the New England Patriots
New England is a team that every game
you don't know who's toute in the rock
all of a sudden it's this no-name
running back well when Bill Belichick
takes a running back that tore up
college football in the first round this
might be the feature guy going forward
Sony Michelle you both love this guy
yeah he should be the future back moving
forward and he can help you in the past
game so he's gonna give you a lot of the
things that Dion Lewis did but he's a
better runner he was the only guy who
could get around the edge against
Alabama when Nick Chubb couldn't he
can't out the rock with speed I loved
his burst his wiggle I had him as 33
overall and he comes off at 31 and I
think the Patriots saw a little alvin
kamara in his tape said let's just find
a way to get the ball in this guy's
hands he's gonna be very familiar
following his other first-round pick
Isaiah wind the guard from Georgia that
went at 23 well and for a team that's
looking for guys that can make plays
with the ball in their hands which they
don't have in New England that's where
this guy makes sense and yes we also
know that they know how to utilize their
running back in the pass game he is
Alvin Kamara with a guy that I think has
just got more power than Kamara as
between the tackles runner out he's
special I mean listen
I I don't care it's the SEC the final
four of this championship game he's
running for 50 and 60 yard touchdowns on
the best college teams in football so I
expect that to happen and once the NFL's
career starts as well man so you look at
the Patriots right now Chris Hogan
cordarrelle Patterson could be all over
the place but they lose em and Dola
elements coming off an injury he could
be a big part of this offense what great
deal I gave it an A I think he will be a
big part of the offense and I've said it
so many times the one of the best ways
to take pressure off of quarterbacks is
give them a running back yes takes the
pressure off Tom Brady sunny Michelle is
gonna do that Sims I'm gonna give it a -
I mean this is a position that is very
important to the New England Patriots
they're gonna split them out slot
receiver he's gonna be between the
tackles runner they're gonna get them on
the edge in the run game but he's a
well-rounded football player tough as
hell a playmaker they need somebody
explosive on their offense that's why I
like it Patriots are loading up for
another Super Bowl run a weapon and a
downhill blocker solid first-round picks
from the state of Georgia for the New
England Patriots
you know Eagles have traded their pick
to the Baltimore Ravens a team that I've
been talking about all along could be
the spot for Lamar Jackson so I got some
news for you
oh crap it's not it is yes Lamar Jackson
so not only do they get Hayden Hearst
the best tight end in the draft they're
gonna give him the weapon for Lamar
Jackson Marty morning wagon Lamar baby
whoa think about who's a run game
coordinator yep the Reg Roman X X column
Colin Kaepernick in the San Francisco
49ers we kind of knew that the Eagles
pick was gonna be up for grabs because
if you get a first-round pick you get a
fifth-year option and for a quarterback
it's very valuable this is exactly what
happened with Teddy Bridgewater Lamar
Jackson is going to Baltimore he's a
first round pick he's ready to go man
I'm in love with this because I think
that's a perfect spot for him I just
don't know how they're gonna do this
with Joe Flacco now well it's okay he's
not ready yet think rg3 signing him was
like a telltale sign that they were
thinking about this I mean that may be
that they were thinking about going
along those lines I don't know if I wish
around him that's a valid point I'm not
I don't know if I want our G no
sarcastic okay okay I know yeah yeah I
you think rg3 I get it listen like I
like how'd you do yo I'm gonna mentor
this guy there we go now RG I don't know
either
well I think Simms are you guys happy
with this right I am extremely happy
it's a great spot yeah I'm uh I'm gonna
give this eight plus this is my guy
right here I'm a big fan as well so why
he's excited we're excited it's just
because we just were so taken aback by
the Bill Polian take so we went hands we
went ham oh yeah what grade did you give
hey hey is a great spot for him man they
got him man
Hayden Hearst and Lamar Jackson that
offense looks completely different now
and with Willie Snead crowd she and John
Brown the question is do you put Lamar
in at a receiver a little and you're one
to get him used to the speed of the game
get used to hearing the calls in the
huddle get used to oh I'm hot off of
these receivers these are all things
that will translate to his quarterback
career I think that's the interesting
dynamic in this combo and he was
disappointed he was still on the board
you can tell oh I'm sure yeah you know
he's gonna use that as motivation all
right let's do this I'm happy as hell
for this guy man we thought the first
round was over we thought that Lamar
Jackson was gonna sit in the green room
and open up his jacket and say who's
gonna come get me and Here Come their
Ravens the Ravens I got a note for you
this guy is gonna turn around the
franchise real quick Lamar Jackson what
do you think
can he get in right away can we see this
goal no he's not Joe Flacco was a
Superbowl fqo you're crazy you're punch
drunk at the end of the drive right no
Lamar Jax is a developmental prospect
who does have to clean up some things
mechanically he has a great arm
he's a dynamic runner he's one of the
most electric players I've seen in
college football in all my time covering
it but he has to learn there are things
he's gonna have to get better at and
they're gonna have to change their
system to accept him you can't run the
same offense for him at Joe Flacco know
this is about the future of the
Baltimore Ravens and it is a very good
pick but he's not going on the field
right now unless Joe Flacco gets hurt
and that's why it's interesting they got
RG three in the offseason what do you
think about Marty mourning wegg horror
ball bryggen Lamar Jackson with Joe
Flacco they're introducing him I love it
I mean and then also Greg Roman is the
run game coordinator who coached Colin
Kaepernick in that offense out there in
San Francisco so he's gonna have a
plethora of designed quarterback runs
did to call but either way I'll say this
about Lamar Jackson is here aw yeah
certainly he's a quarterback let me just
tell you he plays the position the way
it should be played he throws the ball
way he doesn't take sacks yes is the
throwing perfect no it's
there's some mechanical issues like Matt
Miller talked about he needs to clean
those up but I will say this you get
away from college football there's no no
no more 20-hour rule you're in a
facility with coaches on you all day
three to 365 seven days a week
those mechanic is mechanical issues are
not gonna bother me he can throw the
ball and then let's not forget he's the
most gifted runner we've ever seen at
the position other than Michael Vick and
he was the best player on the field and
every ACC game I watched your first
college player to have back-to-back
3,000 yard passing 1000 yard rushing
seasons your grade trading up to get
Lamar Jays and hey I love the trade up
because you get five years with him
which is so important for his
development also because you do have a
quarterback there that won you a Super
Bowl you can't just kick him completely
out the door here at the tail end of his
career so I really like the pic I know
you guys do as well yeah been asking for
it all night yeah yeah no I do it's an
eighth pick for me because it's the
perfect situation to just for him to sit
behind Joe Flacco a little bit what did
I do a play plus what am I talking about
is Lamar Jackson let's go Baltimore but
yes I love this position he's in sit
behind Joe Flacco learn the NFL game I
wouldn't be shocked if you throw them
out or receiver let them hear Joe Flacco
called the plays in the huddle let him
understand the speed of the game oh this
guy makes me hot as a quarterback I got
to know that as a receiver too it'll all
translate so this is not just a project
where we're not gonna see him on the
field for two years they'll find ways to
get in there here exactly right exactly
right
Lamar Jackson easily one of the most
dynamic electric and splendid players to
come out in this trap and they get them
that fifth-year option if this is a
redshirt year that last year is so
important Lamar Jackson the future faced
by the Baltimore Ravens
all right now on a serious note what are
the Eagles get for that don't get a haul
it overall pick in the draft a second
round or next year in another late round
pick okay
no you didn't have to get the second
round or next year to with that it's
just to go bang out we're on 32 to 52 I
don't give a damn sitting up soon as I
don't know I need to stand up alright so
looking at the first round in general
what was what were some of the best
picks in your minds I think Derwin James
at 17 we're all feeling that I think
Mike Hughes at 30 was a great pick
Quintin Nelson at 6 Bradley Chubb at 5
and Edmonds at 16 Tremayne Evans at 16
I'm in the first round I did not have
there was not too many guys I disliked
in the first round this year I mean I
think the other thing too is the Harold
Landry fall was something Harold well
yeah so of course well I mean Miller
seta and our Conner reported it I mean
the fact that there's that kind of
medical issue out there that's a lower
back knee injury for a pass rusher
that's that's bad
are you surprised that will Hernandez is
still in the blue I am surprised I
thought that he would go somewhere
between 20 and 32 but I don't think
Miller's is surprised that he's still no
I'm really not I mean he's a good player
but we saw a run on interior offensive
lineman so it's just that they're going
to be seven interior often sublime
addressed worst pick of the first round
I know you know I know everybody's a
shot you know I go Colton Miller called
Miller's up there hope Miller was a bad
pick and at least trade it back Baker
Mayfield that one was the worst pick of
the first round I'm sorry that's just
that's the truth of the matter I think
it was Rashad penny I didn't like
Edmonds either to Pittsburgh
they could have to make they could have
took Baker med may feel that for and got
say Kwan Berkeley at one and nothing
went and they would been yeah for me I
think that the team that did the best in
this draft other than like the single
guys the bills getting Josh Allen and
Charmaine Edmonds is really inquiry
really incredible night when I read back
was nice I don't real I don't think I
realized how close I actually had Rashad
Penny and so on it's shown Sony Michele
excuse me I couldn't spit that out one
of my favorite picks
the first round that I'll say though
that cuz we didn't get to do videos this
year and you didn't get to read through
my notes ax is the safety Pittsburgh
duck Jermaine Edmonds brother Tyrell I
see you guys are complete personal man I
love Terrell I just didn't think anybody
would have the guts to actually caught
but that was where I Blake when I put at
the end of my notes I put he was gonna
go somewhere between thirty and thirty
and forty five the other one that I
think it was a great pic is if you can
get Minka Fitzpatrick at eleven for the
dolphin yes yes worked out really well
yeah alright guys that was the first
round we are going to be back tomorrow
live YouTube BR at Facebook we're doing
the second and third round it's gonna be
us three and Connor Sims gonna do the
second round with us and then I'm
leaving
and he's bouncing out how to love this
crap look man we're gonna give it to you
straight
unfiltered raw and we're only gonna
focus on the players because that's the
only thing that matters Miller good
stuff Big Ben Sims good stuff he's a
Connor Lily Lily good stuff guys thank
you so much join us wherever you want to
watch tomorrow you know what to do
bleach your report we are with you
holler at you